-Great to see you, Blake.
How are you?
-I'm well.
Thank you for having me.
-It's always a delight
to see you.
You certainly had
an interesting season.
You had a knee injury, and then
of course the pandemic happened.
How are you doing now?
-I'm good now.
I've had a lot of time off.
Just kind of doing
the same thing every single day,
waiting for the next season
to start back up again.
So it's still a little boring,
but it's nice.
-What's the most boring thing
that you've done
to pass the time
that people would be surprised
to know Blake Griffin does?
-Um...
I mean, I don't know
if it's the most boring thing,
but I have played over --
at least over 400 games of
Monopoly Deal, the card game.
-[ Laughs ]
That sounds pretty boring.
-Yeah, it is.
It gets a little interesting,
you know,
when you have the rivalry.
I've got three buddies
that I play with.
So, to us, it's a little bit
more interesting,
but, yeah, it's not great.
It's not great.
-You know, unfortunately,
the Pistons
did not make it into the bubble.
But I imagine time
for the players in the bubble
has been
an interesting experience.
Have you talked to
any of your fellow players?
And what has their reports
back to you been
as far as how it's been
for them in there?
-I have.
You know, I think the consensus
is that the first ten days
maybe was okay,
and then it got
a little bit boring,
a lot more boring,
and then it got
a little dreadful.
But the best thing I heard was,
like, when the games started,
obviously, there's no fans,
and they'd pump in crowd noise,
and it's all screens around.
One of my buddies was like,
"It feels like
playing basketball
inside of
a 'Black Mirror' episode."
-[ Laughs ]
-So, you know, they're doing it.
-Of course, on top of everything
else that happened this year,
you know, we had the sort of
upheaval about racial justice.
And it seemed like the NBA
was at the forefront of that,
you know, up to and including
the boycott that happened
I guess a few weeks ago now.
How do you feel like the NBA,
particularly the players,
have responded to this unique
moment we're living through?
-I thought they've done
an unbelievable job.
I mean, I'm obviously
very biased, but, you know,
I'm proud to be sort of a part
of that fraternity of guys
that have chosen
to use their voice to --
to, you know,
speak out for people
that may not have a voice.
And I think the NBPA and the NBA
all did a great job
of coming together and saying,
"Hey, look, this is important.
We're going to play basketball,
but we want these guys
to be able to express themselves
and stand up
for what they believe in."
And, you know, it's fun
not only to watch basketball
and, you know,
everybody to stay safe,
but also to be able to,
you know, stand for something.
-We first met in 2012
when you did something
on the Espys that I hosted.
I, at that point,
was unaware of exactly
how comedy-talented you were.
Now I think the secret's out,
obviously over
the last almost ten years.
But was this something --
was comedy something
that was always
an interest of yours,
even, you know,
before recent history?
-Yeah, I mean,
I just always loved comedy.
You know, I watched comedy shows
as a kid with my dad.
And I sort of -- Like,
middle school and high school
was, like, sort of the
Comedy Central era, I guess,
where I was just watching
everything on Comedy Central.
I watched "SNL" growing up.
So I've always had an interest.
And then, you know,
I just have had the opportunity
to do fun stuff
like the Espys skit that we did.
And those are the things that
I really, like, enjoy doing,
so that's kind of
how I got into it.
-Would people on sort of
your high-school
and college basketball teams,
would they have said that
Blake Griffin is the funny one?
-Um, I guess it depends
on which guys.
-[ Laughs ]
-I definitely --
-It always depends
on which guys.
-Exactly. I definitely --
You know, I was always trying
to make friends laugh and stuff.
But, yeah, I don't know.
I think some people may
find me funny, but, you know,
I'm sure there's a lot
that don't.
-My -- We have a friend
in common, Neal Brennan,
who, you know, also met you
during that Espys shoot.
And, you know,
he's a standup comedian,
and you've actually
started doing --
You've done some standup comedy.
You've hosted some roasts.
Is this something
that you still do?
-Yes. I --
Neal has been great to me.
He's sort of my comedy mentor,
sort of took me under his wing
and let me see
how it really works.
But I do host a comedy --
a standup charity event
every year.
I wasn't able to do it
this year, obviously,
but I've done stuff for that.
Neal's done that show.
So, nothing right now,
but, yeah,
I have gotten on stage.
It's -- It's absolutely
terrifying, but it's always fun.
-I think it's nice
for people to hear
that you are also
terrified by it,
because too many people think
it's unique to them
that they're scared
of getting on stage.
So thank you for sharing that
and letting them know
that it is for all people.
-Yeah, of course, of course.
-So, your podcast,
"The Pursuit of Healthiness" --
what made you do this podcast
about this area?
-I've always been interested
in health and wellness.
My mom was very into health
and nutrition.
And you know, my brother and I
were, like, the weird kids
when friends would come spend
the night,
we had, like,
the healthy cereals
and we had to like, take
our vitamins in the morning.
And I don't think people really
wanted to spend the night.
So I think that
kind of got me started
in the health-and-wellness
world.
And then, you know, in college,
I was a health-and-exercise
science major
and got approached to do
some podcasts here and there.
And I really wanted to do this
because I wanted
to be able to talk to people
who are leading
their respective verticals
in the health-and-wellness
community.
And it's been awesome to hear
their stories and to learn.
And, you know, if you can
walk away taking one thing
and adding it to your life
that benefits your health
mentally or physically,
then I'm happy about it.
-You've talked to some
really interesting people --
Chelsea Handler.
Karlie Kloss.
Ariana Huffington, who --
You guys talked about the idea
of, like, a good night's sleep.
And she was on this show,
and we also talked about it.
And what she told me
has really stayed with me
as much as anyone
who's ever been here has said.
-Yeah, she --
I mean, she was unbelievable.
I mean, not only just sleep,
but also just the importance of,
like, rest, too, mental rest.
But one thing I loved
that she told me was,
like, you have to have,
like, a sleep routine
to get to the place where
you can finally go to sleep.
And that's something
I've sort of tried to implement,
especially during this
quarantine, COVID time,
just because
my schedule's been set.
We haven't been flying all over
the place playing games,
and I've been able to do that.
And I've definitely
seen a difference.
So, I was -- I really,
really enjoyed my conversation
with her and everybody else.
-I want to ask before you go
about "The Last Dance."
I think for everyone
it was exactly what we needed
when it came out because
we were absent of sports.
But you were a little
disappointed because
"The Last Dance"
robbed you of something.
-Yeah, I've been
a Jordan athlete
for almost eight years now
and gotten to spend
some time around him.
And, you know,
whenever he tells stories,
you're always really locked in.
He's a great storyteller,
and he told us the story
about Dennis Rodman
going to a --
needing a "vacation"
in the middle of the season
and going to Vegas.
And for so long that was, like,
my go-to, like --
People are like,
"What's Jordan like?"
I'm like, "Oh, I got something
cool. Here's this story."
And I would just, you know,
give them
this Dennis Rodman story.
And then as he started
to tell this story during
"The Last Dance,"
I was just like,
"Ugh, I don't have, like,
that cool story anymore."
Like, my go-to story
where I had everything keyed up.
So now I've got to -- I've got
to think of something else.
-Yeah, now you're just a dope
like the rest of us
who saw a documentary.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
-Hey, Blake, it's always
a pleasure to see you.
Congrats on the podcast.
And best of luck next season.
-Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me.
-All right. I'll see you soon.
Blake Griffin, everybody.
"The Pursuit of Healthiness"
is available on Audible.